[Musique]
ce jour-là fab m et son guitariste
arnaud travaillent sur des maquettes le
nouvel album prend forme
après deux ans d'écriture faber travail
sur son troisième opus
c'est une longue phase de travail
finalement c'est pas forcément celle que
que les gens voient le plus c'est à dire
qu'on met souvent des belles photos ans
quand on arrive en studio mais il ya
tout un travail en amont et c'est ce que
nous sommes en train de faire avec
arnaud et puis quatre ans partager avec
les autres musiciens donc un long
travail de plusieurs mois
fab à mayran boli temps il se lance en
solo en 2007 l'artiste délaisse alors le
rock pour se diriger vers la folk la
chanson française son premier ep sort la
même année ça s'est fait naturellement
et puis je pense que même s'il adore le
rock jeu j'aimerais vraiment faire du
rock je pense que je suis meilleur
chanson française camp rock ne serait ce
que pour la voix j'ai une loi je pense
plus plus feutrée plus posé pour du rock
ça pas forcément l'idéal un premier
album vraiment en 2009 qui a qu'à lancer
un petit peu entre guillemets mama ma
carrière et m'a permis d'avoir une
reconnaissance au public et les
professionnels et
mais aussi d'enchaîner sur un deuxième
album des concerts paire de seins petits
juges et les yeux on a tort quand il
n'écrit pas ses séances de répétition
faber prépare son nouveau concert après
sanseverino les blérots de ravel
il fait la première partie de goven cers
faber fait une vingtaine de concerts par
an à rambouillet en ile-de-france et
dans l'hexagone maintenant on se connaît
assez avec les musiciens donc on n'a
plus besoin de répéter forcément à venir
tous les jours où se voir aussi
régulièrement lorsqu'on a des séries de
concerts on va essayer de se voir deux
fois par semaine pour travailler ici
et donc ça c'est pour les séquences
vraiment de répétition concert sinon moi
je vais aller seul
quasiment toutes les semaines
tous les week-ends pour travailler mon
cell dit à roy ou travailler ne
serait-ce que des reprises
nous sommes aujourd'hui femmes aiment
travail avec jusqu'à quatre musiciens
amis de longue date ou rencontre récente
je me souviens de d'apprendre un morceau
à la guitare à fabien qui commençait
tout juste la guitare donc ça date on
devait vraiment avoir enfin moi je
devais avoir 14 15 ans elle peut
peut-être même 13 et voilà et depuis il
a fait des beaux progrès et il m'a
dépassé
heureusement ça fait à peu près un an ou
marc contacteur en disant qu'il y avait
besoin d'un guitariste et du coup bah
c'est avec plaisir que je suis venu j'ai
bien fait bah parce que déjà je
connaissais fable savais que ça va être
sympa il reste pas sur sur ses acquis je
vois quand on compose des chansons il
essaie toujours de chercher quelque
chose de nouveau
je remets en question aussi une dizaine
de chansons est en préparation favem et
ses musiciens prévoit d'entrer en studio
au mois d'octobre
[Musique]